- For all of y'all Jayma, Erinn, Bridgette
be honest who was the bigger
Diva on set Alex or Keanu?
- I can't answer that until
I know if the movie has been
locked and if there's a chance
I can still get cut out.
- She's like wait, no I
have heard though, honestly
that both of y'all are just
such delights to work with.
You're so respectful, you're so kind.
You go out of your way,
that's honestly why I felt
bold enough to ask the question.
But that's so awesome like
just people that have been in
the business you know done what
you've done in your career.
It's very easy for people to drink
their own Kool-aide, we
all know those people.
But you still realize you're
not on a different level.
I feel like a lot of people
that gets lost on, do you agree?
(nervous laughter)
Oh everyone's afraid, I'm the only one
not afraid to get fired or something.
- Let's be real, let's be real.
How it was is that we had to brush
Keanu's hair every day five
times before he went on set.
We had to give Alex some
hugs, I'm done lying.
- I had a lot of knowing my lines
and not crying on set, so diva.